so I kept I'm rewriting the title this
is not a bad title for this class
another way of looking at it is instead
of trying to move forward from here
where everything is confusing and the
present looks like reality we want to go
out to the future and bring it back and
we talked about some process and methods
today we're going to talk about a few of
the gazillion things of course I didn't
get done last week which made this week
even more and finally the side scoot I'm
going to do this both of these talks
again without an audience to do them to
their natural length because the destiny
for this is being online and online
people are not confined to 50-minute
hours I'm sure Sam was all for that
great so again here's my email address
of all the people who are tuned in to
this talk and in the classroom I got
three emails one of which was
interesting that means that either or
both of my talk isn't interesting or
your not interesting or both so try and
least disabuse me of the latter okay so
start off with here's Leonardo pretty
smart guy imagine if you were born with
twice Leonardo's IQ think of how easy it
would be to get into Stanford maybe you
do have twice Leonardo's IQ but suppose
you were born with twice Leonardo's IQ
in 10,000 BC how far you going to get
zero zip right before they burn you at
the stake or whatever they did back then
yeah so here's a guy with nowhere near
Leonardo's IQ Henry Ford and whereas
Leonardo could not invent a single motor
for any of his vehicles think about that
so here's farty wasn't that smart Henry
Ford was able to put together processes
that allowed him to make millions and
millions of cars for about eight hundred
dollars a piece and the difference
between the two was that Ford was born
into the right century and Leonardo was
born into the wrong century and so the
knowledge that had accumulated in the
19th century made much more difference
than any level of smartness and where
did that knowledge come from it came
might as well pick Newton if you're
going to pick anybody it came because
the context was changed from the Middle
Ages and the Renaissance to something
completely different in the 17th century
and Newton made the biggest change of
anybody and so we can call that change a
change in outlook we could call it a
change in context world view point of
view whatever you want so the numbering
rules for you I decided to go back and
start with zero so the zeroth rule here
probably the most important one is to
make progress here content you move this
guy context or point of view is worth 80
IQ points if you've got the context of
science and math your gazillions of
times smarter effectively than the
smartest people of antiquity like
Archimedes a person who learns calculus
with an IQ of 110 or 120 can do things
that the greatest geniuses of the past
can't do ok so we can sum that up by
saying knowledge is silver context is
gold and IQ is just led to lead weight
on you biggest problem with most people
who are at your level and going to the
next level is you're always the smartest
people in your in your classroom or room
at home but that only means you're the
smart
person amongst 30 or 100 and if you
happen to be a room that had 100
smartest people in the world and you
were the smartest person in that room
you're still not as smart as the other
99 working together so being clever
doesn't do it and this is the simplest
there is the IQs there Tony Hoare really
great guy was here at Stanford for a
while touring winner said debugging is
harder than programming so don't use all
your cleverness fright to write the
program anybody recognize this anybody
anybody write programs here let me see
hands yeah so people are so clever
writing the program they forget the
debugging is harder that's true about
anything so that's principle number one
we had zero and here's a summary of what
I showed you and the number two one at
the top there is that the goodness of
the results correlates most strongly
with the goodness of the funders this is
the simplest way of summing up the past
because you have to realize the
difference in the past wasn't that the
people were smarter back then we weren't
smarter than the smart people today
every generation has really smart people
the difference in whether you get
enormous results or not is in this
context idea and the funders that
support it one of the ways of thinking
about them is as opposed to getting gold
medals like a bunch of us have gotten in
our 60s and 70s forty years after he did
the deeds good funders give out the gold
medals ahead of time knowing that 70
percent of them are going to turn to
lead because the funders give it out
before you've gotten the results so this
this will be a slide that you can use
later on it's basically what I said last
time last time we looked at four systems
sketchpad we didn't really look at the
Engelbart system but it's easy to find
out about online we looked at the first
really good gesture system Grail and we
saw that ivan sutherland again
invented BR a long long before it ever
came to use and I really rush past
personal computers and the first thing
was kind of like a personal computer it
was kind of cute was Harry Huskies
Bendix g15 in the mid 50's so this is
really early Harry just left us a few
years over the age of 100 really
wonderful guy here's my vote for the
first real personal computer called the
link by wes clark wes clark also did the
building size computer that sketchpad
was done on so we like to work both
large and small here's one I did with Ed
Cheadle looks kind of modern and an idea
I had in 1968 which struck me really
deeply not because it was a tablet but
because it was the thing that children
needed and I'd learned from Seymour
Papert what children could actually do
with computers and that sees me in a
romantic fashion and we looked at this
idea of better and perfect or the enemy
of what is actually needed in other
words you have to draw thresholds in
order to know where you are else you're
just measuring local variations you
don't know whether they're good or bad
and the last thing we did on Tuesday was
looking at this process of taking a
glimmer of an idea out 30 or more years
to see if it makes more sense 30 years
from now than it seems to now and if it
does you bring it back simulated by
making supercomputers that allow you to
do the software and you know five or
eight years later you've got something
that will revolutionize the world this
is where the trillions rather than ten
billions comes in because you create an
industry and last time I didn't get a
chance to show you kind of what an exam
just one of the examples of what part
did so I thought I'd do it today and
this is a self-portrait because now I'm
I I have extracted stuff from a demo but
this is a system we brought back to life
from 1978 so you get a chance and this
is a self-portrait so this is the
successor to the alto called the
dourados that had now an X bigger than X
VGA screen rather than the portrait
model and this dithering technique was
invented at the same time in the 70s by
Bob Floyd and Steinberg and partly done
at Parc so this is what a typical image
on only a few computers in the world
look like back then one bit for point
and where do we get this system from
well here's the Xerox dump and if you
look closely there there's a disk pack
actually got jacque's throughout most of
the disk packs of the work that was done
at Xerox PARC few of them got rescued
here's here it is a few hundred files on
there one of them happened to be most of
a system that we did in 1978 and it's a
partial interest because the next year
it was the stuff that Steve got Jobs got
some shown during his famous visit to so
you have a little flavor here now what
we did is we brought this back to life
and it's relatively easy because this
system is called small talk small talk
seventy-eight is a pure object system
and so it resembles the Internet this is
a Internet self-portrait and it's just
as good as self-portrait or small talk
because the idea was to have the
one-to-one correspondence between the
idea of little logical computers which
is what we called objects that could
send messages around and make an entire
system and so it's a little different
than from what you think object-oriented
programming yesterday
one of the consequences is that there
are no actual applications because you
can mix and match objects as you choose
well here we see something that is
vaguely familiar I thought I'd turn that
off okay so this is a typical screen
back then and ran on the alto they're
the portable note-taker and the Dorado
here's a bitmap painting I did 45 years
ago that we found and stuck in here see
the user interface is with the object
itself and here I'm marking it up and it
has a character recognizer just a
recognizer like Grail did it's
recognizing I want an arrow and making
one the overlapping windows the icons
what would be called rich text today and
you can see the gesture recognizer is
being used to tell it how to justify and
the system is organized in terms of
projects so each project you can think
of in today's terms as a separate
desktop there persist over time I think
about this compared to the user
interface today where you use an
application that doesn't have every
feature that you want and you start and
stop applications and try and cut and
paste between them here what you have is
just working spaces an unlimited desk
for every project that you have you can
have as many they persist over is over
time because this is a workflow idea
we couldn't get Apple to adopt this idea
and so these are kind of thumbnails of
each one of them we can go into one of
them here's a little thing done by a 13
year old girl writing an article for
creative computing back in 1975 and so
you can see it's sort of like desktop
publishing says but in fact any object
can be used in here and so for example
if we look here she's telling about this
how she used the program and now she's
typing
in there she's typing in code it's being
executed to grow the box and turn the
box and and so forth all right get the
idea so be nice if Wikipedia had even
thought about this right because imagine
you go to the article on logo guess what
you can't execute logo code in there why
it's on a computer what didn't they get
about computing well pretty much
everything so if you look at it closely
you'll see the web design and the web
browser or to the worst things ever done
in computing because they fail to take
account of the fact that you're actually
on a computer okay another example here
is an animation system you notice that
ball is not squashing there and it would
look better if the ball is squashed when
it hit so if this were a normal system
and it didn't have that feature we'd be
done but we can relate objects to each
other so here we're single stepping to
get to that frame that we'd like to
change we're looking at the interface of
this bouncing guy and we're look at
seeing oh yeah there's a thing called
current frame that's what this thing is
and here's our painting window and let's
look at its interface and here's
something that allows me to set the
picture in there and I want to connect
the two windows together so I use the
gesture recognizer to draw a line
between them gives me a little place to
explain how I'd like to relate them and
I say well the painters picture wants to
be the bouncing animations current frame
okay everybody get what's going on here
so I say okay go ahead and do that and
now it's latched on to that thing that's
there now I can start the animation
going again but while it's going I can
paint look carefully and you'll see that
the thing is being painted while it's
running would you like to be able to do
that today I'm just think about why not
this is like sketchpad right except a
few years later yeah this is completely
natural it's what you get very very
easily if you just have unlimited
objects so in this particular thing
gives you automatically something much
more powerful in PowerPoint because all
you have to do is sequence these things
call projects or the desktops that's
what I'm doing here
I'm just moving from one to another so
that's an example of what happened at
Parc and if we go back to this screen of
the various inventions there we can look
at it's not man Tsering Sam's question
well how much of the alto idea actually
made it out of Xerox PARC well about
half will see that see what the other
half is in a second how about the the
GUI well about 70% because you notice
the GUI didn't come out as something
that has this unlimited desktop idea
even today 30 some odd years after this
nobody has put it in there it's
ridiculous but it has to do with people
wanting to have applications and cell
applications even though most
applications won't do all the things
that you need how about desktop
publishing about 70% for the same reason
the way we did programming only about
10% has come out and I won't go into all
the differences but I think you've seen
some of them laser printer about 90%
PostScript 100% that's partly because
the guys who did this at Parc formed
Adobe guess key and Warnock and so they
sold as in their company what it was
that how they thought you should be able
to do printing a hundred percent of the
Ethernet there was no competitor about
50% of pierre-pierre and client-server
we'll see why in a second
100% of the internet again there's no
competitor for it there's no and so one
way of looking at this is what came out
most successfully with the things for
which people already out there didn't
think they already knew how to do it so
everybody knew how to program and so the
biggest resistance was and how we did
programming that just didn't didn't make
it now here's three things I mentioned
before because none of them made it but
one of them was hey the architecture of
the alto was revolutionary and allowed
you to run very high level languages
very efficiently and to make changes on
the fly and we tried with Intel and
Motorola to get them to adopt these at
architectures for the chip and zero
Intel especially at the time didn't know
anything about computing didn't know
anything about programming and didn't
want to learn they had to be dragged
kicking and screaming even to do CPUs
and ego for instance was against the
first CPU on a chip that Intel did the
idea of the Dynabook didn't make it out
think about it
when did the iPad decide to put a stylus
in a keyboard on the iPad right the iPad
pro they couldn't why couldn't they do
it what was their problem so 10% of that
idea came out and here's an interesting
idea to think about here we've got the
the internet of machines connected
together and if your programming
language happens to be a software
internet like small talk was then you
can map the objects into the network and
you can migrate the objects around each
object is self-contained they do
messaging the messaging is either done
internally or goes out on the Internet
and so you have a solution for all the
different scalings of computing that you
have whether it's a small device yes
design book foot so important about the
stylus and keyboard well so here's the
thing two-year-olds use this and ninety
two year olds use this and everybody
else uses tools for dealing with media
so and just see Steve decided not to do
styluses he completely went away all he
was doing was selling sugar water it's
the babies he was not selling something
for instance that any artist can draw
and when I first yeah and he sent me the
first iPad for my comments on the thing
the first thing I did was to go out and
get a capacitive stylus and draw lines
with a ruler on I guess it was Autodesk
one of the Autodesk software that was
pretty good and I determined that the
touch sensitivity on the iPad is
fabulous despite the fact that it's done
in a very very complex way because it
has to find centroids from wide things
on it but it was done extremely well and
I got very linear results on it and so
it was there to do but there was no
place to put the stylus on the iPad and
long long ago remember I showed you a
tablet system from the mid-60s 50 years
ago so we had a perfect chance to decide
by experiment whether a purely stylus
driven system was actually enough to do
the work that you wanted to do and the
answer's no
similarly with Engelbart you could do
every piece of text entry without using
the keyboard but they had a keyboard
there because you just can't do it fast
enough for being able to put in large
amounts of text you need to have a
keyboard it this is well so here's the
thing that angle Bart said they said
well why do you have to learn your
system back then he said well people are
going to use their computers for six to
eight hours a day and they laughed at it
so what you guys are doing
c16 1352 is using your computers for six
to eight hours a day and using
interfaces that are made for a couple of
seconds a day that if that isn't the
most ridiculous thing you've ever it's
about as ridiculous as this building if
you think about it as a user interface
right come in the door and there's a
stairway and there's no map and where am
i where can I go and Jesus this looks
like a dungeon and remember computer
human interface is part of what you're
supposed to learn about and you can't do
it in a dump like this
you have to have some sense of design
around and I'm not sure you can do
software without having some sense of
design around so how could no I won't
won't make any really rude remarks but
so and just to use up time I don't have
I should point out that you know some of
this migrating object idea was done at
Parc
a really great follow up was done by a
visitor to Park Gary Popek who then went
who was at UCLA went back to UCLA and
did a fabulous system using UNIX as the
base called locus loc us and if you're
interested in looking at a future that
will some at some point actually happen
you can get that book from MIT press
and it's particularly the first couple
of chapters of that book outline what
the issues are for dealing with real
scaling on the Internet
I won't go further than that so zero so
the principal 21 reality is a low-pass
filter you have to have enormous ideas
in order so that people not
understanding them will retain something
you don't want to have the pet low-pass
filter give you back a dial tone that
happens on because most of the I you
know most ideas a mediocre down to bad
even
by people who have good ideas those are
the ones that you don't want to work on
because if you're successful on them
they're still going to get peeled out so
here's a book this I put this slide up
here for Sam because Sam reads books few
people probably don't but this is book
this is not a book about Xerox PARC Sam
this is a book by an executive execs
written in the 60s before park about
trying to get the Xerox machine adopted
and this was after Xerox had been the
fastest-growing but one of the one of
the companies that turn down the
complete rights for a licensing fee to
the Xerox machine was IBM that story is
in this book and IBM's consultant said
well this isn't going to work because
there's no market for plain paper
copying because people are not copying
well of course it wasn't a good copier
back then and so I could write a book
our use with Xerox to trillions nobody
wanted I didn't have time to make a
picture that looks like John des hour so
it doesn't matter I'm going to try and
explain to you in the time I have left
why the goodness of an idea is almost
irrelevant now for the reality kit get
out your reality kit and we're going to
deal with the top so just break the seal
and just open up the thing and this will
work best if you put it down on your
thing like this but and look at the look
at the instructions for people online
you get a reality kit okay everybody got
one what happened where were you boy hey
you know what you guys must have been
late take them hand them out to anybody
else okay you're killing me guys okay
so cover your right eye look at the plus
with your left eye and then slowly move
the thing in keeping focused on the plus
until something happens slowly move slow
slow as in the word slow who see who's
seeing something what do you see
disappears on the flight everybody
seeing that don't say yes if you not
this is a good thing for everybody
addictive computing to do once a day
right okay so now let me ask you what do
you see where the block dot was nothing
Wow yes how can that be resolved in
smoke and fog what the radar business
doesn't stop it what it is good to see
you're eligible
no one's ever said it suppose what's
wrong with what the traffic but why
that's what expect okay so here's what's
happening here you see something on fits
right so what's happening is inside your
eye there is one if I got a laser yeah
over here is where the blood vessels
come through so we have a very badly
designed eye if you're arguing with the
creationist this is a good argument
against God here because
because if there was a God he gave
squids
a great eye and he gave us a bad one our
eye happens to have the blood vessels in
front of the light detecting cells and
so our brain has to figure filter out
all of those also and over here is where
most of your acuity is in an area called
the fovea and so when the thing is
further away you get something like this
and when you move in at some point the
dot gets over where there are no
light-sensitive cells at all and you
can't see it anymore
and as my friend over here said somehow
the brain fills it in and we'll look at
that in a second so principle number 22
is we have a blind spot in our eyes that
our brain makes up stuff to fill in it's
just making that up think about this
because what's the other case where your
brain makes up stuff that you think is
real a dream most people think the only
dream at night but in fact human brains
are set up so that we actually dream did
you get one of these so in the old days
we'd throw chalk at you but there is no
chalk okay and a powerful idea about
that is number 23 is that we can't learn
to see until we realize and admit that
we're blind and the biggest problem with
most human beings is they don't
understand that they are blind because
they think they can see this leads to
most much of the trouble in the world
and the powerful idea about that is the
0th one again is it makes a huge
difference if ideas are experienced in
as many ways as possible in other words
perspective point of view is worth 80 IQ
points just because something seems to
be right this is why math is a danger
about thinking okay let's go to the
poker chips now
pry them loose okay and what you're
going to do is hold them up like this so
one is about twice as far away as the
other like that okay you'll see
something like this
all right on your retina is actually
something like this think about if it's
twice as far away it's subtending half
the angle and therefore it should show
up as half size but it doesn't show up
this half size and we can put stick
these guys on a ruler
since these poker chips and now yours
you can take it back and really science
the out of it here's what we should
see that's what's on our retina
Descartes by the way got an ox eye and
peel the back of it off to see whether
biological lenses actually acted like
glass and lenses and they do and here's
what's going on so the stuff that's on
your retina gets backed into about
twelve different places in your brain
your brain in computer terms the cells
in your brain are like the hardware and
there are processes going on and one set
of processes are all the ones that have
to do with our belief system and before
we recognize something it goes through
our belief system and then it goes into
the real-time version of our belief
system which is called the dream so we
have beliefs in the dream and our
beliefs are damned but these things are
the same size by the way you can do this
with oranges with quarters anything
where you know they're the same size
do the same thing and so the result of
information from the actual world
combined with your beliefs you wind up
with this and everybody who's anybody
here is an artist who can draw okay you
must know this illusion then right it's
called size constancy and it's why one
of the things did you learn that I mean
can you actually draw yeah did you raise
here you can draw right so you can
actually draw first thing you realize is
you can't see what's going on and so you
start measured hold your arm rigid you
measure it off so I can measure Sam's
head is that high and Wow it's only half
size compared to this guy who's closer
to me doesn't look like it to me he
looks like it's almost the same size
because I heads are the same got it so
the principal 24 the mind's eye is
different than our sensory eye and we do
things according to the mind's eye and
most people who have ever lived on this
planet don't know that there are two
different eyes because they take the
world as it seems they build up a common
sense from the world as it seems so this
is why human beings generally cannot
think you can't think if you're doing
this stuff so another term for beliefs
is a private universe we each have one
of our very own
if you've ever argued with somebody
thought was reasonable up to that point
what's happening is your beliefs are
conflicting with their beliefs our
waking dreams are private I love this
phrase this is a new phrase alternate
truths
Kellyanne Conway that's what's going on
so you can see why being a scientist is
tough a scientist has to get around all
of this crap that our brain is throwing
up
okay so quick easy model is how random
this is is a little bit of rain water on
dirt dislodges a few crumbs of dirt and
little gully happens and the gully is
more efficient at rooting water so
things start happening just where things
start happening originally you get
something like this
completely random it could have gone any
way and make a whole world out of it
here's a world that's completely pink if
you ever been in the Grand Canyon it is
just almost overwhelming if you look up
you actually remember to look up there's
a little bit of blue sky up above and a
problem with human beings is we don't
look up we look out so here's an example
that's pretty washed out but here's a
that's a pink plane and our thoughts are
like ants crawling over it we can think
about things we can make progress we can
run into an obstacle we can get around
the obstacle and so forth but everything
we're doing here is pink except we don't
know it's pink because we've never been
in anything else but pink so this is
like a fish not knowing it's in water
it's always been in water every once in
a while you might have a little outlaw
thought a little blue thought but you've
been to school you're going to Stanford
you go to church temple synagogue mosque
whatever it is because our beliefs
project out and when we see something
that isn't normal normal is actually the
same as crazy smash but maybe you're out
for a run you're just waking up in the
morning you're taking your shower and
all of a sudden you get a holy
holy there's a blue world full
world it's orthogonal to the one I'm in
once you're in that blue world you
realize oh there's probably a lot of
them and these can you see each one of
these as a context can you see that what
happened from the Renaissance by Newton
to our modern age was going from a pink
plane to a blue plane okay this is what
our putting it went from mainframes a
completely different way of thinking
about things to to the world we have
today despite the fact that nobody had
thought of it at all it was considered
literally crazy by our colleagues in
computing when we were doing it okay so
here's the comfort you just leave the
compass on there it's for you to
remember that some people get to this
really early
Einstein was five he was recovering from
having the measles I think his father
brought him a little compass for him to
play with and Einstein remembered later
in life he said this made the most
impression of me of anything in my
childhood because the way he looked at
it oh there must be something deeply
hidden behind things he didn't take it
as it came because he was worrying about
how does inveigle know where to go
because nothing visible about it yet it
is doing this and that changed
Einstein's complete way of thinking
about things okay so when a baby is born
when we are born we're not born into
nothing we're born into a culture most
cultures over the last hundred plus
thousands of years where traditional
cultures hunting-and-gathering cultures
and traditional cultures don't know that
they are inside a particular outlook
traditional cultures think they're in
reality and so they react incredibly
strongly to other people's versions of
reality to the point of war and many
people this is what our genes give rise
to and many people today including in
our country are born into this pretty
natural way of looking at things we have
to invent the idea about
in well here's another one so if you
happen to be born here you're not you
can have the same baby and bring it up
here the baby will go into being French
French and it's Outlook French in
language and so forth here's a big idea
what happens when books got invented so
a guy by the name of Marshall McLuhan
asked the question what are books
what is writing as an environment if you
thought of writing as being brought up
in France what would that actually mean
to the human race
turns out it's profound take a look at
it if you're interested
you also ask what is media as an
environment so for example what does
this as an environment 24/7 think about
it not that the kids are being told to
shoot people but the problem is they're
seeing shooting people as normal because
what environments do is to take things
and normalize them they make them into
part of reality and make things
thinkable they don't say what to do and
of course media that we have today is
doing exactly the same thing and most
people don't realize okay so unhook the
last flap here there's a little desk top
here table top so look at the picture
there first and before you start
experimenting let me make an assertion
that the tops of the tables are exactly
the same shapes I've been doing this
hundreds of times and I can't see it but
if I take by plastic thing and move it
over there
yeah no it isn't crazy we are crazy if
you remember nothing else from this
course remember that the natural state
of humanity is to be crazy because crazy
is not having good models in our mind
for what's going on out there we just
draw the line at certain kinds of crazy
but we are actually crazy so this is a
really good one isn't it happens to have
been first done here at Stanford this
guy is Roger Shepard
and that is his book it's full of these
okay so good last couple of got it yeah
I think I would get through so
anthropologists over the last hundred
and twenty years or so studied several
thousand traditional cultures and wrote
down properties of these cultures that
were never absent so if a single culture
out of several thousand did not have a
trait then that trait was removed so all
of these traits are thought of as human
universals virtually all of them are
genetic and here's a book you know books
are actually useful it's another good
one to read this is it yeah I I became
very friendly with sam'l I notice I
could not mention a book to him that he
would not have read the next time I saw
him that's how you know it's a good he's
a good guy
okay so the basic idea is genetics
drives culture genetics has the the
precursors the desires and culture fills
in the parameters so you can think of
these they're all category names and
once that list was made people got
interested in things that were not in
every culture and he this is a partial
list of those so agriculture had to be
invented it's a pretty easy invention
but was only invented about 12,000 years
ago out of several hundred thousand
years of us being on the planet so
initially it was a hard thing for
hunting and gathering people to think
about we've got like every animal we
have zillions of genes to help us cope
with things we can deal with hardship
like every animal incredibly but the
idea of progress had to be invented it's
really an invention of the 18th century
and the reason is is that for almost all
of human existence people died in the
same world that they were born into
almost nothing happened and so what you
had to do to get from birth to death was
to cope it's only been recently that the
idea of know we could shape the world to
be better that's a new idea these are
all powerful ideas oral language versus
writing and reading the differences are
profound stories superstition religion
and magic versus the representation
systems of science news remember news
never introduces a new category right
what you hear about is oh it's this
forest fire it's that war it's this
murder it's this kind deed this is why
news can happen so quickly that's what
our mind craves what we hate is
categories because it can take us couple
of years to learn a category so you
never hear any news about calculus takes
a couple you
is to learn it and there aren't enough
people fast thinking versus slow
thinking differences over similarities
this is one of the reasons why most
programming languages go bad web browser
went bad whereas a modern way of
thinking about things the similarities
over differences
emphasize the similarities has many
things to do also equal rights and
democracy vendetta and revenge those are
the favorite movies and the favorite
video games are revenge games personal
revenge games where the system has gone
bad and somebody has to break the law to
put things right
we just love that trope but in fact the
whole legal system was set up in order
to avoid avoid thousand-year feuds and
vendetta's okay so you can think of this
side we have things that human beings
want and simple way of thinking about
them is every single one of them on this
side is a legal drug and for people in
this class who are trying to make money
by being entrepreneurs just make a
technological amplifier for any of these
things that we crave genetically look at
the things that are there hunting and
gathering social language language like
the telephone stories news theater all
of those things that's your list just
get this book right there and make
something that will make people worse
and they'll buy the hell out of it
because we don't have we don't have any
natural all of these things are in
shortage in the world that human beings
have been into except for a couple
hundred years ago over here we have
things that human beings need and
they're terribly you can't really see
but these are terribly difficult to
learn because they not particularly
genetically prepared for they had to be
they had to be invented
okay so last shot here 21st century
going on to the 22nd century
hey we're not born into France or a
traditional society anymore we're born
into a universe that is unbelievably
large a planet that most people don't
even realize we're on yet not just our
social system of a few hundred people
that we know but millions of social
systems and billions of people a
technological system that is starting to
touch everybody in many many different
ways it's only been for instance modern
medicine really dates from only World
War two that's a long time ago for you
folks but it it's within my lifetime I
was born before World War two and before
world war two you simply did not get
antibiotics when you have an infection
was that soon doctor doctoring was
almost quackery so most much of
scientific medicine has happened in the
last 50 or 60 years and then we have the
system of our mind there's not just
social but psychological cognitive and
so forth and so we can sum up this world
that we're born into in this century as
the systems we live in and the systems
we are think about that the difference
between that and what most people think
that they want these are the systems we
have to learn about and deal with and
these systems are not separate I've
mentioned them separately but they're
all intertwined with each other they're
all invisible okay and I'll just leave
you with this last slide so we found out
about all of these systems they were
invisible until a few hundred years ago
and some of them invisible to a few
years ago and the human tragedy is in
two parts part of it is just
finding out something in our
civilization doesn't automatically
transmit it to people born into the
civilization alright the educational
system has to be changed in order to
reflect this stuff and the composite
picture here is that part of our brain
the genetic part of our brain even
overlaid with this stuff still has these
reactions and ways of thinking about
things are not thinking about things
that go back a hundred thousand years so
I think with things like television to
look at things like video games to look
at things like Facebook's to look at if
you're going to go out and make a
company that is going to appeal to
people try to do it without appealing to
the parts of their nature that they're
helpless in front of because one of the
things that those of us who helped
invent the technologies of today are
quite worried about now is that the
technology is so much easier to invent
than it is to change the educational
system and so what we've got is the
informational equivalent of K people
with nuclear weapons but now their
informational weapons and in many ways I
think these weapons are more dangerous
because by renormalizing human attitudes
and human beliefs could very easily
bring down our civilization and put us
back into the Stone Age the talk on
Tuesday may be a little thicker today
but the whole impetus behind the ARPA
research and inventions of these things
and particularly people like Engelbart
was to try to invent new tools and new
media for humanity get itself out of its
problems and Engelbart for example said
almost everything important
that has consequence in the in the adult
world is done by adults working together
and so this is why his system was
collaborative from the so here's an
interesting thing so then here's a Mac
some people have Linux some people have
windows on it here's the interesting
thing not not a single one of the main
operating systems today has built into
it the thing that Engelbart showed in
1968 which is the intrinsic ability to
share any content that you're looking at
with everybody else to the point of
allowing them to interact with it and to
talk back and forth right Skype that
doesn't do it so this is the thing that
is that an operating system-level it's
not a trivial thing to do it is possible
to do but not a single operating system
used today does it and so the ability to
actually work collaboratively on content
is been held back by notions of
operating systems that go back pre-1965
all three operating systems we have
today that are the main ones are old old
ideas they don't even get to where Park
was on the notion of how processes can
coordinate with each other there are
many many other of these things because
these operation operating systems are
rather similar to each other and because
they're pervasive unless you use your
reality kit you're going to think that
they're normal and therefore that's the
way things should be many people in
computing have a misplaced notion of
Darwinian process like like most people
most people think Darwinian processes
optimized that is absolutely not the
truth
one of my degrees in molecular biology
and I can tell you any biologists would
say they absolutely not optimized the
whole point of Darwinian processes is to
fit into some in some niche in some
environment and if that environment
isn't the right kind of environment the
process of evolution is not
can give you something that's very
interesting that is the way it works and
as computing gets less and less
interesting its way of accepting and
rejecting things it gets more and more
mundane so this is why some of these
early assistant like Sam look at
sketchpad so why aren't they doing it
today well because nobody even thinks
about that that's important nobody even
thinks of doing WYSIWYG on the on the
web on web media I just typed in some
answers to Cora and I was in a a regime
that was pre seventies I was typing into
a little window I couldn't see what it
was going to look like until I clicked
the button
come on this is but nobody is
protesting except old fogies like me
because I know it can be better you need
to find out that it can't be better that
is your job your job is not to agree
with me your job is to wake up find ways
of criticizing the stuff that seems
normal that is the only way out of the
soup you have to go against your genetic
impulses to try and learn the
environment around you it's the most
natural thing we have but it's not going
to help because the environment is weak
and if you learn the environment you're
going to be weak
[Applause]